[MUSIC]
We are joined by some of our
colleagues from Financial Aid,
and so this is our chance
to really talk about that.
And so, Elizabeth,
could you please introduce yourself and
tell us a little bit about your role?
>> Hi everyone, yeah,
my name is Elizabeth LIamas.
I am the Associate Director of
Financial Aid here at the GSB.
Very excited to be
joining you this morning.
So I work with all students, veterans,
everyone to help them through
the financial aid process, and
then also support you while
you're a student with the GSB.
>> Cool, so
can you tell us a little bit about
what's financial aid like at the GSB?
What's the process?
>> Sure, so for most students,
we've built a system around three
guiding principles that we want
to instill in our process,
excellence, access, and fairness.
And so when we talk about financial aid,
we do have a combination,
in general, of fellowship and loans.
And we're looking at a student's
income and assets which is, very,
if you've been through a financial aid
process before which some of you may have.
This is probably very similar,
something that you're familiar with.
We have as far as the process goes,
we have our own financial aid portal for
our students.
So it's a one stop shop portal for
you that's customized to your situation.
And it's a great tool for our students
to connect with our office but
also to submit everything to us very
securely, so very excited about it.
>> Cool, and
then knowing our audience today,
can you tell us a little bit more
about opportunities for veterans and
especially maybe can you touch on
Yellow Ribbon Program, please?
>> Definitely that's probably chapter 33,
post 911 Yellow Ribbon
is definitely one of the most common
VA benefits that we have at the GSB.
And so for those who are maybe looking
to use their Yellow Ribbon benefits for
the first time,
essentially once you're eligible and
you receive your certificate of
eligibility you'll have 36 months.
Our program is built around a 9
month financial aid budget, so
you'll be using about 18 months for
the two years of your benefit.
And Stanford is committed to
supporting our Yellow Ribbon
veterans as much as possible.
So our match with the VA funding
will cover up to your tuition.
So that's a really great thing for
our veterans that they don't have
to worry about the tuition costs.
For those who maybe are not
Yellow Ribbon eligible, we still have,
like I said other methods of financial
aid to help support you as well.
>> Cool, and then what about folks who
might be interested in the nonprofit or
government sectors?
>> Yeah, so, yeah, we have a, and I think
I know where you're going with this.
We have a really awesome loan forgiveness
program if you do find that you need to
borrow loans to help supplement
your educational costs.
And so that's for students who are looking
to go back into a government sector or
possibly into the nonprofit sector.
This program has been around at
the GSB for a very long time.
So over ten years,
it's a well established program.
It is our own,
it's completely independent from
the government's loan forgiveness program.
And if you do enter into one
of these sectors essentially,
we will help you assist you repay
your loan balances as an alumni.
So it's a really great opportunity for
those who are thinking about going back
into the nonprofit or public sector.
>> Cool, and then as I'm thinking about
financial aid and prospective applicant,
do you have any tips, best practices,
things that we should be keeping
in the back of our mind as we're
going through the journey?
>> Definitely so Stanford's has
their own veterans department, OMAC.
I'm not sure if you've already touched
on that in the past section, okay.
So we work hand in hand with OMAC, so
it's really important, as you start
to get this information that you're
not only in communication with us but
we will also assist with communication
with the OMAC and come together.
The earlier you can get your
documentation ready the better.
So that's going through whatever
VA process that you need to,
especially getting that
certificate of eligibility.
And so if you need assistance as far as
the next steps, we definitely ask that you
reach out to us or to our colleagues at
OMAC to assist you with that process.
But other than that,
we're here to support you.
So if you're admitted, we will walk you
through the necessary steps to apply for
financial aid.
>> Cool, so the OMAC that we referred
to a couple times as the Office for
Military Affiliated Communities
at Stanford University.
And this is not just a GSB organization,
but
one that helps support our veterans
across our whole community,
both the undergrads and
the different grad department.
So once again, OMAC in the Office for
Military Affiliated Communities.
Now, let's say I'm an admitted student,
is there any way to kind
of understand what I could be
getting as a financial aid package?
>> Yeah, so once you're admitted we do
have a calculator tool which we encourage
all students to use to get a better
understanding of what they may qualify for
before they begin
the financial aid process.
So that will be available to
you as an admitted student.
>> Cool, and then one other thing
knowing that kind of from experience,
what about families?
Oftentimes we think about, hey,
I'm applying to business school as
an individual, but for many of our
applicants, there's either a significant
other, or there's children who are
going to be participating in this journey.
How does that factor into financial aid?
>> Yeah, so our cost of attendance
which is essentially the budget for
the program,
is built around your circumstances.
So if you're single or if you're married,
and if you're married if you're bringing
any children or
dependents with you to the GSB.
So, of course those costs may increase for
you.
For our Yellow Ribbon recipients,
you are eligible for
a housing allowance on top
of the tuition payment.
So you would be receiving that monthly
as well to help offset those costs.
>> Cool, thank you just we've
covered a lot of ground-
>> [LAUGH]
>> In actually really impressive
amount of time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Are there any other things that from
you, having sat in your seat for so
long, any other words of wisdom or
things that you would love
to share with the group?.
>> Yeah, I mean it can be scary
approaching financial aid
in general or
some people find it kind of stressful.
The people in our office,
my colleagues and
myself, we've been doing this for
a very long time.
And I've also been a certified
official for the VA, so
I know what you need to go
through to get your benefit.
And so my tip to everyone is
just to start conversations
as early as possible with our office.
We're here to assist you and we would love
to help you walk through this process and
make sure that you feel
secure about your package and
how you're going to afford the GSP.
>> Nice, all right, so
those were my questions.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If you can't tell there's a lot of
joy in our office and we're going to
extend that joy to the group.
We're going to open it up right now.
Are there any general
financial aid questions or
funding questions that folks
in the audience might have?
So feel free to pop those
into the Q&A box, and
let's really make the most of our time
with one of our financial aid experts.
Again, my hands are pointing in this
direction because that's where her window
is in my screen.
I don't know where Elizabeth might
be on your screen so that might.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But this is the time to ask.
See if you have questions here.
Here's a question from Krista, when is
the deposit for the program typically due,
assuming you're admitted,
when do you have to make that deposit?
>> Yeah, so the deposit is,
we'll jump in if [LAUGH] I believe deposit
is due by the time that you accept your
admissions offer, is that correct?
Great, so it's due upfront as just for
once you had made it you'll have
to receive your financial award,
really weigh your options and then commit
to the program and accept your offer.
And that's when your deposit is due.
I will for the VA, with the VA
benefits the one thing that is not
covered if your post 911 eligible
is a deposit for our program.
But you're still fully covered for
your tuition and
the deposit will go to offset
other costs of the university.
>> Great, all right, here's a question
about dual degree students.
How is the GI Bill and
the Yellow Ribbon benefits applied
towards dual degree programs?
>> Yeah, so essentially,
with a dual degree program,
you're looking at most likely a little
bit longer than an 18 month program,
which is normal for an MBA student.
So depending on the dual degree that
you're admitted to, it could be,
24 months, etc.
As long as you're,
enrolled in an educational program,
that your VA benefits will continue
to support your education.
And so, like I had mentioned,
once you're eligible for Yellow Ribbon,
you usually have, if you have not used
it before 36 months of benefits, so
it's quite a bit of time and
we're only using about 18.
So if your enrollment
extends past that 18 months,
then you'll have continued eligibility.
>> Great, thank you.
Here's a really important
question from Carolyn.
If you do not qualify for
Yellow Ribbon due to partial GI Bill,
are there other financial aid programs or
scholarships that you recommend?
What's to that extent?
>> Yeah, yeah, so if you're not eligible
for a VA chapter that covers your full
tuition, then we encourage you to apply
for our Need-Based Fellowship Program.
Which is what I talked about
a little bit in the beginning,
where we look at your income and assets.
And you go through the process
like a normal student, and
that, if your are eligible for
fellowship that can help
offset those additional costs
that are not covered by the VA.
Additionally, we do have some resources
that you will have access to for
external scholarships.
And we definitely encourage all
of our students to look for
additional opportunities
outside of our office,
and we're also here to help
you with those opportunities.
So we have a general list for
you to work off of.
But there could be more
opportunities in that for you.
>> Yeah, and Elizabeth,
correct me if I'm wrong, but
last-
>> Yeah.
>> Wasn't the average
financial aid package around
$40,000 per year per student?
>> Yeah, it was around $40,000 for
our students, and that's per year.
So that can definitely help
supplement what the VA is giving you
towards the tuition.
>> Great, here's the question.
So the application process,
we're need blind in applications.
So that means that how you're going to
finance your time at the GSB has no impact
on the final decision.
So our financial aid process
is need-based okay, so.
>> Correct.
>> So a clarification there.
For the applications, there's three
rounds, so round one, round two,
round three.
Is there a difference in financial
aid funding among the three rounds?
>> There's definitely not.
We've committed that whatever round
that you're admitted to the GSB in you
will have the same opportunity for
financial aid as those in round one and
two versus three, or
any combination of those.
So same opportunity,
any round you apply for you're admitted
you still have the financial aid
opportunities as everyone else.
>> Great and
here's one a little bit about housing.
So, knowing that this-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Financial aid covers a lot of ground
here, is the housing stipend you mentioned
with Yellow Ribbon different than or
in addition to the housing allowance
received while using the GI Bill,
do happen to know?
>> No, it's the same.
So it's the BAH housing allowance
as part of the GI Bill,
and it's going to be based
on Stanford's zip code.
So if you're interested,
you can head over to the VA website.
Our zip code is 94305.
And you can check out what your benefit
level will be with the BAH housing siphon.
>> Great, and
then one question here, actually,
there's a couple questions
along this theme.
So need-based financial aid,
can you talk a little bit more about what
are a couple of the elements there and
then is it based only on those?
What happens if there's something in
my life that isn't captured there?
>> Yeah, so the intial application
is going to ask you for
several years of income
as well as your assets.
And when we talk about assets, we
are looking at liquid and illiquid assets.
And then we always leave,
we want to take a holistic approach
to your financial aid package.
And so we're opening it up to if you have
a circumstances that you think impedes
your ability to pay for your education,
we definitely want to hear about
those in your application.
So we have an opportunity for
you to explain and if for
some reason you have
extenuating medical expenses or
possibly are supporting your family,
we want to know about those.
So there's an opportunity for
you to explain situations outside
of what we're asking for.
>> All right, so thank you again,
Elizabeth, for jumping on and helping.
That was a lot of really helpful,
meaty information.
>> It was a lot.
And for those who have been asking
questions, thank you for your engagement.
If you didn't get your
questions answered live today,
we're going to continue answering some of
them over the course in the Q&A box as to
the best of our abilities.
Also, feel free to jump on our website,
I keep referring folks back to that.
It's going to be one of
your best resources.
Continue asking us questions there.
We are here to support
you along this process.
[MUSIC]